if we have to simulate the entire
universe
to create the ornaments and the two of
us
how are we supposed to create engineer
life
yeah that's not this goes back to sort
of the critique of the rna world i think
one of the problems
and and i'll get to answering your
question but i think this is kind of
relevant here
one of the problems with the rna world
um when we test it in the laboratory is
how much information we're putting into
the experiment
we specify the flasks we make pure
reagents we mix them
we take them out we put them in the next
flask we change the ph we change the uv
light and then we get a molecule and
it's not even an rna molecule
necessarily it might just be a base
right um and so people don't usually
think about the fact that we're agents
in the universe
making that experiment and therefore we
put a little bit of life into that
experiment
um because it's part of our biological
lineage in the same sense that a couple
or i am a part of the biological lineage
the experiment ideas
are injecting life yes
and the constraints that we put on the
experiments because those conditions
wouldn't exist in the universe
on planet earth at that time without us
as the boundary condition right
so even though we're not actually adding
any actual like
chemistry or biology that it could be
identified as life
are the constraints we're adding to the
experiment the design of the experiment
yeah you could think of a design
experiment as a program you put
information in
it's an algorithmic procedure that you
design the experiment and so
um so the original life problem becomes
one of
minimizing the information we put into
physics
to actually watch the spontaneous
original life can we can we have
so can is it possible in the lab to have
an information vacuum then
so like if we could we would that would
be amazing i don't know that's a good
question for
more for lee yeah you guys by the way
for people who don't know lee cronin
is uh you guys are uh colleagues and
uh i've gotten the chance to listen to
the two of you talking
there's great sort of chemistry and
you're brilliant brainstorming together
and there's there's a really exciting
community here of
brilliant people from different
disciplines working on the problem yeah
of life of complexity of uh i don't know
whatever
the words fail us to describe the exact
problem we're trying to actually
understand here intelligence all those
kinds of things
okay so what what uh
from a lab perspective so lee i guess
would you call
him a chemist no i think by training
he's a chemist but i think most of
people that work in the field we do have
lost their discipline
that's why i couldn't answer your
question okay i don't know what you call
yeah i don't know what i call myself i
don't know what i call any of my friends
so why why is it so hard to create uh
and it's an interesting question to
create biological life in the lab
like from your perspective is that
an important problem to work on to try
to recreate
the historical origin of life on earth
or echoes of the historical origin i
think echoes is more appropriate i don't
think
asking the question of what was the
exact historical sequence of events and
engineering every step in the process to
make
exactly the chemistry of life on earth
as we know it
is a meaningful way of asking the
question and it's a little bit like
um you know if since you're in computer
science like if you know the answer to a
problem it's all it's easier to find a
program to specify the output right but
if you don't know the answer or priority
you know finding an algorithm for like
say finding a prime or something it's
easy to
um you know uh verify it's a prime
number it's hard to find the next prime
um and uh the way the original life is
structured right now in the historical
problem
is you know the answer and you're trying
to retrodict it by breaking it down into
the set of procedures where you're
putting a lot of information in
and what we need to do is ask the
question of
how is it that the rules of how our
universe is structured permits things
like life to exist
and what is the phenomena of life and
those questions are obviously
essentially the same question and so
you're looking
essentially for this missing physics
this missing explanation for what we are
and you need to set up proper
experiments that are going to allow you
to probe
the vast complexity of chemistry in an
unconstrained way with as little
information put in as possible
to see when things when does information
actually emerge
how does it emerge what is it um
and um part of the the sort of
conjecture we have is
that this physics only becomes relevant
or at least this is this is
my personal conjecture and um and it's
sort of
uh validated by this kind of theory
experiment collaboration
um that we we have working in this area
um that this you know sort of i made the
point about like gravity existing
everywhere right
but when you study um an atomic nucleus
you don't care about gravity it's not
relevant physics there right
it's it's weak it doesn't matter um and
so
uh this idea that that there's kind of a
physics associated with information
for me it's very evident that that
physics doesn't become relevant until
you need
information to specify the existence of
a particular object
and the scale of reality where that
happens is in chemistry because of the
combinatorial
diversity of chemical objects that can
exist
far outs exceeds the amount of resources
in our universe
so if you want to you can't make every
possible protein
of length um you know 200 amino acids
there's not enough resources
so in order for this particular protein
to exist and this protein to exist in
high abundance
means that you have to have a system
that has knowledge of the existence of
that protein and can build it
so existence comes to be at the chemical
level so the existence is most
is uh best understood at the chemical
level it's most evident
it's a little bit like nobody argues
that gravity doesn't exist in an atomic
nucleus it's just not relevant physics
there
so the physics of information is
everywhere it exists at every
combinatorial scale but it becomes more
and more relevant
the more set of possibilities that could
exist because you're
you're you have to specify more and more
about why this thing exists and not the
infinite it's not an infinite set but
you know the set of undefined set of
other things that could exist
you